you
we're here on a runway because for some
reason Brady has printed out the first 1
million digits of pi on a continuous
mile long piece of paper which we are
going to very carefully unravel today
and go for a tour of a million digits of
pi so here's 3.14159 which if fun fact
that's as far as I've memorized and then
it carries on and you've marked every 10
every 10 digits so there's a hundred
thousand marker points through so we
won't get lost we'll always know where
we are in pi was the faman point is that
seven hundred and something is this the
fame in point two six nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine so that won't be
beaten there is a string of seven threes
but that takes another seven hundred and
ten thousand digits so we'll be nearly
three-quarters of the way down the mile
of pi before we find a longer string of
the same digit and the first one is
within the first two meters absolutely
incredible
you're nice for that bring the single
gun back
we've just hit 123 yards and so we're
long past the familiar bits of pie so
the whole 3.14159 as a long time ago you
think anyone who's memorized pie we're
now in unfamiliar territory apart from
one guy that is the world record for
memorizing pie so someone recited was
that now we're over 125 yards of pie
someone memorized all the way up to here
and couldn't be bothered to remember the
next zero not even whatever
there is a run here of seven ascending
digits there it goes zero four five six
seven eight nine nine that is the first
run of a seven digits that go up
obviously we're missing one two and
three would be nicer with them but
nowhere in the first million digits do
you get zero to nine in order so three
and three three hours
well half-mile from the start and the
trollee team are they on the horizon
okay
pi has just got a horizon
okay see that for there it appears to me
on their square and I'm a kind of fun
but then for here you go wait there's no
force no for no for no for in fact
there's no force until they let well
then look at that 157 digits and there
are no force there are no force for that
entire run they've just vanished
there's the longest run we will have in
the first million digits that has one
digit completely missing
you
with a million decimal places a pie each
digit should appear approximately a
hundred thousand times each that makes
sense but of course it's not exactly
even some of them don't even make it
there are not a hundred thousand zero
zero doesn't make it one doesn't make it
six seven and eight all don't make it
the champion though is five here it is
that there is the a hundred thousand
five
okay we're four hours into this and we
are nearly at a million digits so
they've been coming out at a rate of a
quarter of a million digits an hour
which is approximately four thousand one
hundred and sixty seven digits a minute
and we're we're almost there so I mean
you guys have done the hard work you
want to whine off the last of this and a
million digits is there there all right
so that is there is what it's a one in
case you're wondering so there you go we
have just I mean I think a token round
of applause right so that is absolutely
fantastic and now the very quick process
of rolling it all back up again before
an airplane lands
believe it or not we printed all million
digits of pi using about eight
milliliters of ink there that's what
eight milliliters looks like that's
because of HP's clever thermal inkjet
technology combined with some very
clever people here at HSA systems in
Denmark to see the whole story of how
and why we made this film check out the
links on the screen and below in the
video description it also includes extra
footage from our day out on the runway
and more curious stuff about pi itself